PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Get Cooking in Cloud,
where we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I am Priyanka.
JENNY BROWN: And I'm Jenny.
And in this episode,
we'll be making
a loaf of gluten-free bread.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yes, we will.
There's a lot going
on in this recipe
that we will need
to pay attention
to-- keeping ingredients
separate from the allergens,
keeping ingredients
separate from each other,
and making sure our
space is allergen-free.
JENNY BROWN: Much like
with cloud security,
we need to keep things
safe from external threats,
and even from mixing internally
before it's appropriate.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Dinner
Winner is an application
that collects recipe
submissions from users
all over the world and
posts regular winning
recipes for everyone to enjoy.
JENNY BROWN: The
recipe submissions
need to be assessed
for clarity and then
scrubbed for any
identifiable information
before they are
sent on to judging.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
The anonymous judging
takes place, after which
winners are contacted
and their recipes are
posted to the application.
JENNY BROWN: Submitted recipes
can't mix with reviewed recipes
due to the potential private
information from contestants.
So it's critical to
uphold that separation.
Just like with creating
gluten-free recipes,
it's important to not only
have gluten-free ingredients,
but a gluten-free space as well.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Exactly.
Our recipe is simple, but
this situation is complicated.
And for Dinner Winner, due to
the high number of submissions,
that's a lot to handle.
JENNY BROWN: Do we need a
dedicated facility or just
a strict cleaning policy?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Well, it depends.
Let's see how their
system works today.
During the competition times,
users upload their recipe
in the text format.
These recipes get
stored in blob storage
from where they're
pretty manually
checked for private information
like emails and phone
numbers of participants.
This private information
is then removed
before sending to
the judges to vote.
The winning recipe then makes
it on the platform for everyone
to see.
JENNY BROWN: The
problem with it?
Well, there's a lot of
problems with this arrangement.
One, because this is a manual
process with a ton of volume,
this system will scale badly.
But the biggest problem
here is security.
It's difficult to know
what's been reviewed
and what's been
updated and what still
has private information in it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: What if
just one recipe submission
gets accidentally shared with
the judges with a contestant's
name and contact information?
This will potentially
make the contest unfair
and can lead to brand damage
for Dinner Winner, which
sounds like a losing situation.
JENNY BROWN: And
since Dinner Loser
doesn't have the
same ring to it,
let's make sure they
can keep their recipes
clean of personal information
just as we need to keep
this surface clean of gluten.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Just
like Dinner Winner,
in every organization,
data protection officers
like you face an ever
increasing amount of data,
data that must be protected
and treated appropriately.
Quarantining and
classifying that data
can be complicated and
time consuming, especially
given hundreds or
thousands of files a day.
JENNY BROWN: And what if
you could take each file,
upload it to a
quarantine location,
and have it
automatically classified
and then moved to the
appropriate location
based on the
classification result?
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: In
the next few episodes,
we will show you how to
implement such a system
by using Cloud Functions, Cloud
Storage, and the Cloud Data
Loss Prevention API.
JENNY BROWN: Dinner Winner
needs an automated process
for sorting submissions
and categorizing reviewed
submissions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
The ingredients?
App Engine for front end, Google
Cloud Storage to store recipe
submission files, Pub/Sub for
messaging, Cloud Functions
for some quick automation
in serverless fashion--
JENNY BROWN: And the most
important ingredient--
DLP API to detect
private information.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now
let's put this all together
and stir it up.
Let's say the front end
is an app engine where
the user submits the recipe.
The user would
upload the text file,
including the recipe
and info types,
like the name, date, email,
and phone numbers in the web
interface.
The uploaded file is sent
to Google Cloud Storage.
This triggers a Cloud Function
to create the data loss
prevention job in Pub/Sub.
JENNY BROWN: Once the event
is received by Pub/Sub,
it triggers another
Cloud Function,
which calls the
DLP API and looks
for the confidential
information in the recipe files.
Once found, it moves the file
to a separate storage bucket.
If the file does not contain
any confidential information,
like the info types email,
address, phone number,
then the function moves
it to another bucket.
This request flow keeps the
confidential data separate
from the non-confidential
and is fairly automated,
such that as soon as the file
hits the Cloud Storage bucket,
all other processes
kick off automatically
to protect the data.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Now that we understand
the problem and the
use case, we know
exactly what needs to be done
to implement the solution.
JENNY BROWN: And
next week, we'll
reveal our step-by-step
plan for Dinner Winner.
And maybe we'll even get
to that gluten-free bread.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Yeah, but first,
we will need to avoid
cross-contamination
by deep cleaning the kitchen.
JENNY BROWN: And since
Get Cleaning with Cloud
isn't quite what
we're going for,
we've got some behind
the scenes work to do.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
While we're at it,
don't forget to give
us a Like, comment,
and subscribe to learn what
you can cook up with the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]